very unusual this isn't it as we
normally only see
sporadic travel related cases what do
you make of it
well we have actually seen an outbreak
in this country in the past in
in about i think it was 2018 where
a small outbreak with a travel related
case who then passed the infection on to
a health care worker
it is
an infection that has been increasing
globally for a few years now and
typically
uh the outbreaks in the west have
generally been associated with animal
contact but this is indeed the first
time that we've seen such a large
outbreak across multiple countries where
there has been person-to-person
transmission outside of africa
and are we any closer to knowing why
that's the case
um i think we've i think there are some
fairly good ideas i think the i it
it does seem to be spreading in um
amongst certain networks of
people rather than more in the general
population although
there is
probably some wider spread
it is
um i think there's a lot of work being
done at the moment to actually nail this
down and hopefully we'll have a better
idea in about a week or two
oh so quite soon i mean that would be
very useful won't it
yeah i mean it's it's a question of
actually tracking down all the cases
looking at where where they've been who
they've been in contact with and then
trying to draw these networks together
to come up with a conclusion about how
it's spread i think it's been likely
that it's it's spread it imported uh
with one or more people from
west africa who have then had close
contact with other people back home when
they're in in europe and that's probably
how it's been spreading
and the good news so far seems to be
that cases in the in the uk appear to be
pretty mild yeah in general in adults it
is a
usually a pretty mild infection that
gets better on its own
typically within about uh three weeks
although sometimes you do get left with
scarring
which
remains with you but it can be severe
particularly in children and also
in people who are immunosuppressed
and probably also in pregnant women
yeah we keep seeing those uh rather
gruesome pictures don't we of the of the
blisters and the scarring that you
mentioned um
will people be offered the smallpox
vaccine do you think i i'm thinking
about people like healthcare workers or
those who may have come into contact
with someone who's carrying it well it
already is being offered to uh contacts
as far as i i can tell
that this is what we did
in 2018 with the last cluster of cases
uh
the approach generally is is known as
ring vaccination so rather than
vaccinating a wide group of people at
least initially you identify cases you
get cases diagnosed and then very
carefully identify their case their
contacts and offer vaccine to them
one of the advantages here is that the
vaccine is actually affected effective
even if you give it after somebody has
had contact up to four days after
contact
so what really matters and how this
epidemic will be brought into control is
diagnosing
cases early and then careful and rapid
follow-up of contacts
and of course following kovid we've all
become rather fascinated in in zoonotic
diseases those that are passed from
animals to humans and and this is an
area of a great deal of research
yeah i mean we
uh it is
an animal uh acquired infection
primarily it probably rodents and and i
think the best evidence is for
african squirrels as the uh source of
this but i don't think that is proven
beyond all shadow of a doubt at the
moment
but and just finally paul um a pretty
straightforward question what should
somebody do if they if they feel or fear
that they they may have it
if they believe they've been in contact
with the case or if they've developed
uh
the rash and it's a rash that looks a
little bit like chicken pox but unlike
chicken pox it tends to affect the face
and the hands and the legs
and
they should really prac go probably to
the local
genital urinary medicine clinic which
you can attend gum clinics without
appointment in this country or if that's
not possible uh visit uh contact your gp
okay uh straightforward advice always
good to speak to you professor paul
hunter professor in medicine norwich
school of medicine
uea thank you very much